[Music]  Ben Affleck moves out of the family home  he once shared with wife Jennifer Garner  here are all the details you need to  know about the former pairs current  status you know I tried might try my  best  a source tells ET the actor recently  left the guesthouse he's been living in  since the couple's initial separation in  2015 but the source also adds Ben and  Jen remained close for their three kids  11 year old violet 8 year old Serafina  and five-year-old Samuel I think that's  the very best thing you can do according  to the source the kids are good they  have their own traditions and things  they'll do together as a family still  we're told Ben has moved into a house  close to Jennifer and their little ones  but as far as their love lives go the  source revealed to eat see they are not  ruling out dating in the future but  neither one of them is dating anyone  seriously at the moment new door best  [Music]  you